so what gender do you think you are
well i'm a male okay well i think maybe
i think you're a woman no legally i'm a
male oh it says on my driver's license
that i'm a member i say i don't believe
you it doesn't matter exactly it doesn't
matter if you don't believe me no it
doesn't matter because biologically what
gender do you think i am
i would assume you're female yeah so
you're making assumptions yes i identify
as non-binary yeah i don't respectfully
it doesn't matter it matters my gender
expression it matters the way that i'm
allowed to express myself it matters
what bathroom i use it matters who i'm
allowed to live with it affects every
aspect of my life so you're saying what
pronouns should i use you should use
they them pronouns so you saying that
what if i don't what if i don't if you
don't i would consider that
disrespectful and that's actually an act
of violence to misgender a trans it's an
act of violence that is an act of
violence to intentionally misgender
someone right so that's a crime
an act of violence against you is a
crime we have no idea how many pronouns
there are we can never know how many
pronouns there are and to not use a
proper pronoun you could ask is an act
of violence against them did you ask my
pronouns before you sat down